Donc on fera bientôt un abordage dans une prochaine leçon plus expositive des doctrines qui sont condensées dans ces paragraphes.
Mais pour l'instant j'aimerais appeler votre attention à nouveau sur les langages immédiatement bibliques,
dans cette chronologie biblique de l'épisode de la Chute et les contenus essentiels de la rédemption.
Donc quand on parle de la théologie de l'Alliance, pour ceux qui se sont déjà portés ou ont déjà eu l'opportunité d'étudier de manière systématique cette doctrine,
ils peuvent vite être intéressés au débat théologique sur les questions de la nature des alliances,
la relation entre la première alliance et la deuxième alliance ou la nouvelle alliance et l'ancienne alliance,
et l'application bien sûr des signes de ces alliances, donc l'application pour les baptêmes, etc.
Donc nous y arriverons à échanger, mais nous sommes convaincus que la manière la plus profitable
d'étudier la théologie systématique, c'est d'en ayant fait un bon travail dans la théologie biblique
et de s'habituer avec les conceptions par une expérience directe avec les écritures,
pour bien poser les bases, pour après comprendre les formulations théologiques qu'on fera face.
Et donc, ce qui est intéressant à remarquer dans la structure de ces deux paragraphes,
c'est la manière dont les premiers paragraphes s'adressent à cette première alliance que Dieu avait faite avec Adam,
avant la chute, et il remarque déjà, je vous avance quelques remarques qu'on va faire,
que même cette alliance-là était les fruits d'une naissance des grâces de la part de Dieu,
car la créature, pour plus parfaite qu'elle soit, elle n'est dans aucune position ou droit d'exiger aucune bénédiction
de la part de Dieu.
Et combien plus de pensées que les créateurs puissent établir une alliance avec la créature.
Et donc, même l'alliance qu'on appelle est remarquée bien,
et ça c'est très important surtout pour nous, les baptistes.
Remarquez bien comment les rédacteurs de la confession baptiste,
elle va éviter, même plus que la confession des foires de Westminster,
d'utiliser l'expression « alliance des œuvres ».
Ok ?
Et donc c'est assez nouveau pour les courants baptistes,
c'est beaucoup plus récent,
de vouloir nommer par exemple l'alliance mosaïque,
au moins dans les contextes populaires,
dans l'origine des confessions des foires,
les premiers baptistes réformés,
ils étaient hésitants,
on va présenter les raisons pourquoi après,
à utiliser l'expression « alliance des œuvres ».
Ok ?
Donc ça, c'est quelque chose qu'on verra plus tard.
Mais c'est important,
même dans la description de la première alliance,
de ne pas mentionner cette question d'alliance d'œuvres,
même si les conditions sont mises en évidence.
Donc ensuite,
on considère que, bien sûr,
en ayant la capacité dans cette première alliance,
Adam,
d'accomplir les conditions de cette alliance,
même si l'alliance était un don, une grâce,
car c'était la possibilité de rendre encore plus parfait,
quelque chose qui était déjà parfaite,
et l'homme avait la capacité d'obéir.
Ok ?
Il n'était pas encore corrompu.
Après la chute,
cette alliance qui j'établit,
est remarquée bien aussi,
nous, les baptistes confessionnels,
qui est la description,
c'est la description d'une seule alliance des grâces
après la chute.
Une seule alliance
qui est décrite dans ces deuxièmes paragraphes
comme une alliance toute inclusive et globale.
Et donc,
ces deux paragraphes nous montrent les distinctions
entre la première alliance et la deuxième alliance,
l'alliance des grâces.
Et à partir de là,
cette alliance des grâces,
elle est décrite surtout par son contenu essentiel
en mettant toute l'emphase sur la question de la rédemption.
Donc, jusqu'ici,
même si la suture d'alliance est introduite,
l'expression alliance est introduite,
la terminologie alliance des grâces est là,
vous pouvez remarquer de manière très claire
par les deux paragraphes
qu'il y a une phase primaire
qui est mise sur la rédemption.
C'est-à-dire,
l'expérience des rédemptions,
des réconciliations avec Dieu
est la substance principale.
Et comme dans tous les organismes vivants,
la vie est plus importante que la suture.
On n'est pas là en train de voir mon esquelet.
On dit mon esquelet ?
Squelette.
Hein ?
Mais vous voyez plutôt l'aspect organique, la vie.
OK ?
Et ce qui est intéressant,
c'est de remarquer
que c'est évident et explicite dans la Bible
que la suture dans laquelle Dieu a communiqué
son plan de rédemption
était une suture d'alliance.
Par contre,
la rédemption et le salut
est plus importante.
La question qui vivifie,
la question des relations avec Dieu,
elle est plus importante
et plus mise en emphase
à quelque chose qui surmonte
et donne du sens même à la suture.
Et donc,
il faut qu'on ne perde pas de vue
l'importance de la rédemption
quand on est en train de traiter
la question de la théologie des alliances.
OK ?
C'était quelques remarques,
on rappelle qu'on a fait
dans la première leçon.
Et donc là,
c'est un petit résumé
de la première leçon
qu'on a vue
la semaine dernière.
Donc,
on a considéré d'abord
pourquoi
l'alliance
ou l'alliance des dieux
avec l'homme,
les chapitres 7,
est quelque chose
qui a été placé
au septième chapitre.
Donc,
on se rappelle très bien
toute l'importance
des autres doctrines
qui étaient là
par une question
des théologies systématiques.
On étudie,
par exemple,
sur Dieu
avant qu'on arrive
à cette notion
d'élection,
de représentativité,
du fait
que les péchés d'Adam
vont transmettre
sa coupabilité
envers nous tous.
Et donc,
comment la sagesse des dieux
qui parle d'un plan éternel
pour la rédemption,
elle incluait déjà
la chute de l'homme
dans les décrets éternels
des dieux.
Il n'y a aucune chose
qui a pris Dieu
par surprise.
Et donc,
bien sûr que ces considérations
peuvent provoquer en nous
quelques questions
par rapport
à la sainteté des dieux,
à la justice des dieux,
par rapport
à la sagesse des dieux,
à la puissance des dieux.
Et voilà pourquoi
on a travaillé
infiniment plus
l'importance
d'avoir étudié
d'abord et avant tout
qui Dieu est,
ses attributs
pour n'avoir aucun doute
des doctrines
plus claires,
explicites
et simples
à comprendre
dans la Bible
qui nous décrivent
par exemple
qui Dieu est.
Et donc,
protégés
par les premiers chapitres,
nous sommes en mesure
d'étudier ces chapitres
en résistant
à la tentation
de commettre
des blasphènes,
si on peut dire comme ça.
Mais en même temps,
par rapport
à la perspective
de la théologie biblique,
l'intégration biblique,
si vous voulez,
ça nous aide
à comprendre
et suivre
la didactique
de la révélation divine.
et donc là,
on a considéré
aussi
la responsabilisation
ou la responsabilité
de l'homme
dans sa rébellion
et le fait
que c'est nous-mêmes
les êtres humains
qui nous sont mis
dans cette misère
et on s'est rappelé
en fait
que l'histoire de la Bible
n'est pas l'histoire
des êtres humains
en cherchant
à régler leurs problèmes
avec Dieu
ou en cherchant
à restaurer
leur vie avec Dieu.
La Bible n'est pas
l'histoire
de l'humanité
qui est à la recherche
de Dieu.
La Bible est l'histoire
d'un Dieu
déterminé
à chercher
son peuple,
l'humanité
pour régler
ces problèmes
qui n'est pas possible
d'être réglés,
n'est pas possible
d'être réglés
par les êtres humains
tout seuls.
Et donc,
quand on considère
la rédemption
dans son rapport
avec l'Alliance,
on considère
que c'est une expérience
plus expérimentale
avec les textes bibliques,
avec la manière
biblique
de décrire
les plans de la rédemption,
de traiter
l'importance
de la rédemption
comme quelque chose
des plus importants
quelque part
qui est de nous plonger
dans la structure
de cette Alliance.
Donc,
les deux choses,
bien sûr,
sont très importantes.
Il n'y a pas
de rivalité entre elles,
c'est plutôt un problème
à nous
et notre attitude
en tant qu'étudien
de théologie
qui peut provoquer
ces problèmes.
Et donc,
ce qu'on a considéré,
c'était de considérer
d'abord
les grands plans
de la rédemption
tels qu'ils sont
surtout affichés
en Ephésiens chapitre 1.
Et donc,
en lisant
Ephésiens chapitre 1,
donc une bonne portion,
on a pu faire
quelques déclarations
à propos
de ces grands plans
de la rédemption
des dieux.
OK ?
Donc,
on se rappelle,
c'est un plan
entièrement des dieux.
donc,
c'est lui
qui a résolu,
qui a développé
ces plans.
Donc,
l'homme ne peut pas
participer
par incapacité,
par manque de sagesse
et par une question
des positions.
C'est Dieu
qui est à la position
suprême d'autorité.
C'est à lui
vraiment de développer
donc entièrement des dieux
et totalement par grâce,
surtout à partir du moment
où on est tombé
dans les péchés.
donc,
c'est forcément nécessaire
que si jamais
on a une nouvelle opportunité,
c'est qu'il part grâce.
Il était planifié
avant la fondation du monde
et ses plans
étaient en plan trinitaire.
Donc,
on a parlé un peu
et c'est une catégorie
des compréhensions
très importantes
et très touchantes.
Elle devrait être
très glorieuse
pour tous les chrétiens
car il y a eu
une conférence
à l'intérieur
de la Sainte Trinité
avant la fondation du monde
pour que Dieu
développe un plan
pour nous sauver.
À nouveau,
la question pour nous
c'est pourquoi moi
et pourquoi pas les autres,
la question primaire
car nous sommes tous
trouvés
dans la même condamnation.
Si Dieu
a choisi
certains
d'entre l'humanité
pour faire partie
de cette alliance
trinitaire,
donc Dieu,
on a vu quelques passages
qui montrent
non seulement l'alliance
entre les Pères,
Fils et Saint-Esprit,
les Pères
qui vont choisir
développer les plans,
les Fils
qui vont
représenter
un peuple défini
et accomplir
parfaitement ces plans
et les Saint-Esprit
qui vont donc
appliquer
l'efficacité
de ces plans
de salut
et de rédemption.
Mais il y a aussi
un traité
encore plus particulier
entre les Pères
et les Fils.
Donc les Pères
qui vont donner
un peuple
à son Fils,
les Pères
qui vont confier
la mission
et qui vont envoyer
les Fils.
et donc il y a
ce qu'on appelle
les pactes
éternels
ou les pactes
trinitaires
de la rédemption
où les trois personnes
sont là
intéressées
dans les saluts
de tous les peuples
des dieux
mais de chaque individu
qui est sauvé.
Et donc là,
l'amour des dieux
pour nous
est ancien
et très solennel.
Donc du dieu
trinitaire
pour nous.
Donc planifié
avant la fondation
du monde,
Éphésiens nous dit
de manière très claire
en lui,
nous avons été élus
avant la fondation
du monde.
C'est un plan
défini
et immuable.
Donc c'est un plan
qui a été défini
selon l'arrêt
des dieux,
selon des descents
des dieux.
Et donc c'est
pour mettre
en emphase
surtout
la perfection
du planning
des dieux,
son omniscience.
Donc c'est un plan
parfait.
Donc Dieu
ne sera jamais
pris par surprise
avec aucun événement
dans l'histoire.
Toutes les choses
vont se dérouler
parfaitement
en accord
avec les plans
des dieux
et dans l'histoire
Dieu est tout simplement
en train de mettre
en exécution
ces choses.
C'est un plan
certain
infaillible.
Voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous parle
de la plénitude
des temps.
Donc on a un peu
parlé sur ça
mais c'est la manière
dont Dieu a permis
ces mondes
de maturer
quelque part,
d'essayer
d'autres sortes
de réconciliations,
d'inventer pour soi
parfois
des faux dieux
et on va dire
même donner
l'opportunité
au développement
philosophique
etc.
pour que
lorsque Christ arrive
ça soit
véritablement
la plénitude
des temps.
pour que l'humanité
soit prête
à reconnaître
qu'elle est seule
et elle est
en plan infaillible.
Donc un plan
certain
et infaillible.
Ok ?
C'est un plan
intégral
et cosmique
donc en éphésien
on voit ça aussi
en faisant
converger
en Christ
toutes les choses
et donc ça
c'est important
de travailler là-dessus
à propos de la rédemption
car la rédemption
a été révélée
progressivement
mais
quelle serait
par exemple
l'une des alliances
qui vous pensez
qui nous parle
de cette alliance
étendue
à toute la création
par exemple
car nous voyons aussi
ces aspects
dans les alliances
qui ont été
communiquées
progressivement.
Noé
donc l'alliance
avec toute la création
par la médiation
de Noé
et donc ça
ça va revenir
dans les Nouveaux Testaments
surtout lorsqu'il
Paul va parler
que nous sommes
les responsables
de rendre
la création
otage
de notre corruption
et la création
attend avec hâte
la révélation
de l'ensemble
des enfants des dieux
car à partir de là
toute la création
sera aussi rachetée.
Et donc c'était
notamment
voilà
une rédemption
qui concerne
les chrétiens
et les mondes entiers.
Et ensuite
un plan centré
sur Christ
ok
donc tout
faisant converger
en Christ
et en plan
et donc voilà
si vous pouvez
bien remarquer
c'est un aspect
de cette grande rédemption
ok
donc quel est l'aspect
c'est révélé
par
une structure
d'alliance
ok
une grande structure
d'alliance
mais révélée
par plusieurs
petites
alliances
ou alliances
plus particulières
comme on verra
d'accord
donc ça
ce sont des choses
qu'on a vues
la semaine dernière
et donc on va avancer
ça c'est les textes
qu'on a utilisés
pour constater tout ça
donc juste un résumé
par rapport à ce qu'on a vu
par rapport à la rédemption
pour conclure
la première leçon
donc qui peut lire
la rédemption
est un plan éternel
décliné
et inouïable
de Dieu
préparé avant
la fondation
du monde
établi par les
trois personnes
de la vie
sans un peu
quand on peut
se couper
dans le cadre
d'une alliance
déclinée
progressivement
par des alliances
susceptibles
absolument
sortantes
et destinées
à la gloire
des vieux
faits
Amen
donc là
c'est une perspective
plus large
de la rédemption
et maintenant
on va
commencer à considérer
ce qui touche
à la structure
d'alliance
qui est donc
l'objet
de ces chapitres
ok
donc voilà
les plans
pour aujourd'hui
on verra
si on arrive
à finir
donc déjà
à l'introduction
oui
l'effet
la sagesse
et la nécessité
de la structure
d'alliance
donc ça
c'est quelque chose
qui doit être
un constat
inévitable
même si
dans l'histoire
de l'église
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
dans les premiers
siècles
on a plein
d'évidences
que la compréhension
des alliances
était présente
même si
la terminologie
et les formulations
ou la systématisation
et l'emphase
qui a été faite
à partir de la réforme
par rapport
à la théologie
des alliances
n'étaient pas
les terminologies
utilisées
donc il voyait
clairement
la continuité
la progression
de la révélation
par rapport
à cette alliance
il voyait
comment toutes les choses
pointaient
envers son accomplissement
mais cette terminologie
elle est plus récente
il parlait plus en termes
des lois
et grâces
mais il citait
constamment
en fait la typologie
donc ça c'était aussi
une autre manière
donc toute la typologie
de chaque alliance
qui s'accomplissait
en Christ
donc essentiellement
les bases théologiques
et voilà pourquoi
je reviens sur ces points
la théologie
était la même
c'est la théologie
qui a été utilisée
par les réformateurs
pour restaurer l'église
et même si les formulations
ont été un peu plus
structurées à cet égard
à partir de la réforme
c'est important pour nous
de savoir
que la compréhension
même si elle n'utilisait pas
la terminologie
théologique
technique
la compréhension
était immédiatement
biblique
vous êtes avec moi
et donc c'est pour ça
que c'est important
pour nous
de bien établir
les bases
d'une compréhension
d'abord et avant tout
biblique
et donc
je vais vous présenter
quelques définitions
essentielles
d'alliance
une qui part
tout simplement
dans le sens comment
et l'autre qui est
la définition théologique
d'une manière
introductoire
et après
on va faire cet exercice
de nous plonger
dans un survol
des alliances bibliques
afin
d'à partir
d'une méditation
directe des textes bibliques
arriver à une compréhension
biblique
de cette notion
d'alliance
donc
la définition essentielle
classique
d'une alliance
c'est
une alliance
est un pacte
ou traité
formel
entre deux parties
souvent
des statuts légaux
ou comparables
mais aussi
entre nations
souveraines
et vassales
ok
ça c'est
une définition
essentielle
donc d'une alliance
donc même dans la société
on peut établir
des alliances
et on aura
un signe
on aura des conditions
on aura
parfois des serments
ou des jurements
des promesses
et des engagements
en intérêt comment
ou en intérêt
réciproque
entre les deux parties
conditions à respecter
pour
pour qu'on puisse
réjouir
et bénéficier
de la promesse
et si jamais
on casse
avec ces conditions
on ne peut plus
réjouir la promesse
les menaces
ou punitions
ou sanctions
en cas de rupture
les bénéfices
ou récompenses
en cas de fidélité
et des symboles
ou rites
pour sceller
donc bien sûr
qu'immédiatement
les pactes
les plus évidents
pour nous
dans notre société
qui nous touchent
à tous
ou à la majorité
c'est tout simplement
les mariages
et à partir de là
on peut penser
même la citoyenneté
ou d'autres
manières
d'expérimenter
par une espèce
de cérémonie
solennelle
une alliance établie
qui pour perdurer
dépend des conditions
c'est important
on verra bientôt
la référence
à ces nations
souveraines vassales
c'est car
dans les temps anciens
et notamment
dans le contexte
de l'alliance
avec Moïse
la pratique
est une pratique
parfois
d'un royaume
qui verrait
s'emparer
d'un autre
dans les disputes
des territoires
des guerres
etc.
et donc parfois
une nation
qui était superpuissante
au lieu
de rentrer
et tout
ravager
ok
il pouvait
envoyer
un représentant
un ambassadeur
pour proposer
un pacte
donc pas toujours
parfois
des pactes
business
des nations
plus ou moins égales
et qui rentrent
dans un accord
commercial
mais dans ces cas là
c'était une nation
qui pouvait envahir
et détruire
et qui donne
la possibilité
à cette nation
plus faible
de devenir
une nation
vassale
un pays
vassal
c'est-à-dire
c'est un pays
qui sera soumis
aux normes
et aux règles
de ces pays
qui va les saisir
mais en retour
au lieu d'être détruite
cette nation
va pouvoir réjouir
des bénéfices
de cette nation
donc l'Empire romain
il travaillait beaucoup
comme ça
dans les périodes
du Nouveau Testament
donc c'est important
de considérer
que quand on pensera
à l'alliance
de Dieu
avec l'homme
donc bien sûr
que nous devons élever
cette condition
à l'infini
l'évangile n'est pas
comme certains
cherchent à proposer
une supplication
de la part
d'un Dieu
complètement
nécessité
pour que les personnes
se réconcilient
avec Dieu
c'est une supplication
qui est accompagnée
d'une sommation
ok
l'évangile
c'est
voilà
la possibilité
des termes
de rendition
avant
qu'on ne soit
détruit
donc l'évangile
prêché par Christ
et par Jean-Baptiste
et là
H
est déjà
mise à la racine
répentez-vous
et croyez à l'évangile
donc il y a
une grande menace
et les profits
est infini
pour les répentis
qui embrassent
cette possibilité
et les malheurs
et enfin
est infini aussi
pour ceux
qui veulent le rejeter
mais la manière
dont on communique
l'évangile
c'est une sommation
ok
une conjuration
car ça parle
du souverain
qui donne l'opportunité
à ses vassales
du lieu d'être détruit
de saisir
cette possibilité
et donc
une définition
un peu plus
plus enrichie
pour faire la transition
entre une définition
commune
à une définition théologique
une alliance
est un pacte
ou accord
entre deux
plusieurs parties
parmi les hommes
il s'agit généralement
d'un accord
entre parties égales
il peut aussi
être une disposition
imposée par une partie
supérieure
à une partie inférieure
acceptée
par cette dernière
il est généralement
confirmé
par une cérémonie
solennelle
et chaque partie
s'engage
à remplir certaines promesses
sur la base
des conditions
stipulées
donc deux choses
que je voulais avancer
tout de suite
la première
c'est que quand on pense
au fait
qu'à chaque alliance
que Dieu va établir
avec l'homme
et l'alliance globale
établie avec l'homme
Dieu est dans une position
infinie
de supériorité
tous les termes
de cette alliance
sont protégés
par sa justice
et par sa bonté
toute participation
humaine
légitime
dans une alliance
avec Dieu
sera
une participation
volontaire
car
on partage
des meilleurs intérêts
qui Dieu lui-même
nous les proposera
par ses alliances
et
les risques
qu'on peut avoir
quand on
met l'emphase
qu'il faut mettre
sur le fait
que Dieu
est la partie
suprême
et supérieure
dans ses alliances
et voilà pourquoi
toute alliance
est une alliance
des grâces
c'est
que certains théologiens
vont vouloir proposer
qui nous sommes
parfois plutôt
devant
un testament
qu'une alliance
donc
pour expliquer
l'intérêt
est légitime
c'est de ne pas
risquer
de donner aux hommes
la possibilité
de comprendre
comme Dieu
est rentré
en alliance
avec moi
c'est car
il y a
une importance
en moi
ou c'est car
je suis en mesure
de traiter
avec Dieu
vous comprenez
pour empêcher
cette attitude
arrogante
de l'homme
certains théologiens
pour vouloir mettre
plus d'emphase
sur l'aspect
de la supériorité
divine
ils veulent parler
en termes
des testaments
et donc
il y a certainement
un passage
en hébreu
chapitre 9
où les termes
testament
est approprié
à la traduction
car là
il est en train
de parler
déjà dans les contextes
de ceux qui sont
réconciliés
avec Dieu
en Jésus Christ
qui sont déjà
dans les cadres
de l'alliance
avec Christ
des implications
de la mort
du Christ
en tant que
celui qui va
nous déléguer
en tant qu'héritier
de ses conquêtes
de manière
irrésistible
et presque automatique
tout ce qu'il a conquis
donc les testaments
quand on laisse
un testament
pour nos enfants
c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on doit avoir
leur accord
ils vont hériter
ce qu'on va laisser
pour eux
car on a décidé
seul de nous-mêmes
de les faire
vous comprenez
la distinction légère
entre testament
et alliance
dans l'alliance
les deux parties
rentrent en accord
ok
donc c'est important
pour nous
de mettre
l'emphase
qui a dû
à cet aspect là
donc je vous ai dit
que j'allais vous avancer
deux aspects
mais je ne me rappelle pas
de deuxième
ou peut-être
que les deux étaient déjà
ensemble
dans ces emphases là
mais bon
une alliance
est un pacte
ou accord
entre deux
ou plusieurs parties
et quand il s'agit
des dieux
en rétrent
en alliance
avec l'homme
c'est toujours
quelque chose
qui est essentiellement
une question
des grâces
donc la définition
d'une alliance
biblique
elle passe par
cette compréhension
de l'aspect
souverain
dont Dieu
décide
prendre l'initiative
si ça part
pas des dieux
si c'est pas
le fruit
de sa grâce
de sa condescendance
envers un
ou plusieurs hommes
ça ne peut pas
exister
c'est impossible
que l'homme
puisse chercher
à proposer
une alliance
avec Dieu
et voilà pourquoi
on parle en termes
des nécessités
de cette alliance
je suis désolé
c'était pas
il faut qu'on reste là encore
et donc
donc
une alliance
publique
est établie
soudainement
par Dieu
par grâce
et condescendance
envers un
ou plusieurs hommes
donc Dieu
seul
elle est garant
donc on n'est pas
devant des parties
égales
mais on est devant
la volonté
et les choix
des dieux
donc l'homme
à partir du moment
où il est
rébellé
contre Dieu
il n'est plus
en position
d'accomplir
aucune promesse
donc bien sûr
que dès la première
alliance
qui Dieu a établi
l'alliance des grâces
avec Adam
après la chute
certains veulent
s'opposer
qu'il s'agisse
d'une alliance
car
ce n'est pas
évident
ni explicite
l'engagement
volontaire
d'Adam
dans cette alliance
mais
donc il y a
deux arguments
les premiers
c'est que
l'effet
lui-même
de la création
il est là
en train
des
voilà
des dieux
en tant que créateurs
parfaits
lorsqu'il vient
proposer quelque chose
c'est évident
qu'il est
de l'intérêt
de l'humanité
ce que Dieu
vient proposer
car
devant quoi
était Adam
les moments
où Dieu
vient les visiter
après la chute
il était devant
la menace
certaine
de la mort
dans tous les aspects
la mort éternelle
et donc
c'est implicite
que la volonté
d'Adam
était engagée
devant cette alliance
proposée par Dieu
mais c'est explicite
son accord aussi
même si pas
dans la stipulation
des termes
ou quoi que ce soit
car c'est pas nécessaire
mais par la foi
qu'il a exprimé
donc c'est
implicite
mais ça devient
explicite
à partir du moment
où nous remarquons
comment de manière
volontaire
Adam a exercé
la foi
envers la promesse
que Dieu avait donnée
et la foi
elle devient
pour les alliances
des grâces
la manière par laquelle
l'être humain
va manifester
son accord
et sa réjouissance
la condition
de l'alliance des grâces
et la foi
et donc Abraham
par exemple
lorsqu'il a dit
sort de la maison
de tes parents
de ta terre
et va à la terre
que je te montrerai
et qu'il promet
à Abraham
une grande descendance
l'habit nous dit
qu'Abraham
a cru en Dieu
et celui-là
a été amputé
par justice
donc la réjouissance
et la participation
dans l'alliance des grâces
c'est la foi
et donc par l'exercice
de la foi
en changeant le nombre
de la femme des femmes
à elle
nous voyons de manière
très claire
qu'Adam
il est là
en train de réjouir
et de manifester
son intérêt
et son aspect volontaire
dans cette alliance
donc ni toutes les alliances
dans la Bible
elles ont tous les éléments
d'une alliance
explicite
devant nos yeux
mais elles ont
les parties essentielles
qui doivent suffire
ok
et donc
en ayant cette notion
minimale
d'alliance en tête
ok
un traité formel
de la part des dieux
avec l'homme
qui va engager
des promesses
et des sanctions
et des conditions
ok
et donc la première alliance
et là on va passer
donc on va faire
un survol
d'abord
des alliances
des principales alliances
dans la Bible
et bien sûr
que nous allons après
nous arrêter
sur certaines
des alliances
donc
d'une manière générale
à partir de la chute
comme on verra
Dieu a établi
une alliance
des grâces
avec l'humanité
ok
par contre
pour identifier
une alliance
dans la Bible
nous devons aussi
nous en servir
de la première alliance
avant la chute
comme les paragraphes
de la confession
nous montrent
mais quand on considère
par exemple
dans l'alliance
qu'on appelle
l'alliance des vies
l'alliance des oeuvres
et pourquoi
on l'appelle
comme ça
car cette alliance
des vies
ou alliance des oeuvres
elle prend en considération
la condition
ou elle prend en considération
la récompense
des fois
l'alliance des dieux
avec Adam
à l'origine
est appelée
l'alliance des vies
car la promesse
était la vie éternelle
et bien sûr
que ce n'était pas
une vie
tout simplement
en termes de durée
car il n'y avait pas
de menace
pour Adam
au paradis
par rapport
à sa vie
et l'âme humaine
restera
pour toujours
depuis sa création
immortelle
qu'elle soit
au paradis
ou à l'enfer
et donc la question
n'est pas
la durée de la vie
qui était concernée
mais c'était
la condition
de la vie
ok
donc la vie physique
bien sûr
qu'elle aurait
fin après la chute
mais la question
de la récompense
concernée par l'arbre
de la vie
c'était une récompense
d'une qualité
de vie supérieure
d'une participation
à la société
divine
dans une condition
supérieure
et donc c'est intéressant
car dans les moments
où Dieu établit
cette première alliance
avec Adam
on se rappelle très bien
il va enlever
Adam
de là
où il a été créé
il est inséré
dans les jardins
des dieux
et à partir de là
Dieu va
établir une alliance
donc à nouveau
c'est une alliance
très implicite
on n'est pas
la Bible
elle n'est pas
très claire
par rapport
à tous les éléments
d'une alliance formelle
à la formalité
de cette alliance
en même temps
c'est intéressant
car tout ce qu'on parle
en termes de formalité
ce sont des choses
qui nous apprenons
et qui nous développons
en tant qu'être humains
dans la société
on n'a pas accès
à la formalité
par exemple
de cette alliance
trinitaire
avant la fondation
du monde
qui nous concernait
déjà
et qui concernait
les serments
qui Christ a prêté
au Père
et la manière
dont il allait sceller
avec son propre sang
mais didattiquement
dans l'histoire
Dieu va développer
tout cela
avec nous
par contre
cette alliance
s'est établie
avec les éléments
qui nous allons
remarquer plus tard
qui font partie
même des alliances
les plus formelles
l'alliance la plus formelle
qu'on aura dans la Bible
c'est celle avec Moïse
et elle suit
les pratiques hittites
de l'époque
de ces peuples là
et donc
ce qui est intéressant
à remarquer
c'est que
Dieu
va suivre
avec Moïse
la même procédure
entre ces deux nations
donc déjà
il y avait un prologue
qui présentait
les parties
ou surtout
la partie
souveraine
ok
si vous voulez
la partie la plus importante
et c'est la même chose
qu'on voit
en Genèse
par exemple
pourquoi la Bible
commence avec Dieu
c'est Dieu
qui entend
se présenter
en fait
c'est les dieux
qui au commencement
ont créé
les temps
l'espace
et toutes les choses
et qui manifestent
toute sa puissance
tout son royaume
les droits
qu'il a
en tant que créateur
donc ça
ça peut être vu
par une perspective
profondément formelle
si nous avons
la structure d'alliance
des bases
dans notre compréhension
car c'est une nouvelle lecture
quelque part
des Genès
même si dans la lecture
naturelle des choses
ça reste légèrement
implicite
et donc
c'est clair
que les temps
que la Bible
elle prend
pour décrire
toute la création
avant de présenter
cet accord
entre Dieu
et la créature
c'est pour manifester
qui était Dieu
les dieux tout-puissants
hors temps
hors espace
et de l'autre côté
la poussière
qui est l'être humain
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc quand on considère
cette alliance
on voit de manière très claire
plein d'aspects
des formalités
même s'ils ne sont pas
très explicites
et donc
la sanction
étant
soit la vie
comme récompense
soit la mort
certaine
donc les symboles
étaient les arbres
ok
et donc
les conditions
ou la condition
était l'obéissance
qui était possible
pour Adam
donc ça
ce sont des choses
qu'on considère
déjà
dans la première alliance
et il y a une remarque
qui est faite
pour
et Rod
qui est très intéressante
il donne l'exemple
par exemple
dans
voilà
il explique plus ou moins
que les fêtes
que
nous pouvons attendre
de la part
d'un Dieu
si bon
si sang
que si jamais
il donne
un oeil
à l'être humain
il lui donnera aussi
de la lumière
vous êtes avec moi ?
mais
c'est une réflexion
fondée
sur la fiabilité
des dieux
sur la bonté
sur la générosité
des dieux
les fêtes
qui dieux
qu'on
conçoive
ok
qu'on soive
aux êtres humains
une capacité
religieuse
ne donne pas
aux êtres humains
les droits
d'exiger
de la part
des dieux
qu'on puisse
réjouir
de l'intimité
avec Dieu
vous êtes avec moi ?
l'être humain
a été créé
avec la capacité
de réjouir
de cette intimité
avec Dieu
mais le fait
d'avoir été créé
est en soi
et de soi-même
une énorme bénédiction
pour la créature
même si
elle reste
dans une certaine distance
de l'intimité
divine
et le fait
que Dieu nous donne
quelques bénédictions
n'oblige pas Dieu
de nous donner
d'autres
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc la réalité
c'est que
cette alliance
avec Adam
à l'origine
même si elle était
basée sur cette capacité
légitime
d'Adam
d'obéir
elle restait
essentiellement
une alliance
des grâces
car l'alliance
en elle-même
était en acte
des grâces
et les récompenses
étaient aussi
en acte des grâces
par contre
à partir du moment
où Adam
a échoué
et Dieu doit
tenir sa promesse
par justice
l'être humain
devrait être puni
certainement
en mourant
tu mourras
c'était
la sanction
et c'est ça
qui retomberait
sur l'humanité
et c'est ça
qui est retombé
sur l'humanité
sauf que
comme on connait bien
en anticipant
l'histoire de la rédemption
pour pourvoir
à l'alliance
des grâces
avec Adam
ok
les moments
où Dieu arrive
pour apporter
la punition
il apportera
mélangée
avec l'espoir
et la grâce
car
cette déclaration
certainement
Adam
en mourant
tu mourras
c'est une vérité
qui a eu lieu
et qui aura lieu
dans quel sens
elle a eu lieu
de manière
diluée
envers toute l'humanité
elle a eu lieu
car Adam
en tant que représentant
de toute la race
humaine
a été remplacée
pour un autre Adam
les nouvelles Adam
qui a reçu
sur lui
cette mort
parfaite
qui représentait
la mort
de tous ceux
qui sont en Jésus-Christ
par représentation
vous êtes avec moi
et toute la descendance
d'Adam
qui n'est pas en Christ
recevra
pour toute l'éternité
cette morte
certaine
vous êtes avec moi
et donc c'est clair
qui est
même si Dieu
va introduire
une nouvelle alliance
envers l'humanité
et qui concerne surtout
une portion
de l'humanité
il n'est pas en train
d'annuler
la sanction
qu'il doit
maintenir
envers toute l'humanité
car toute l'humanité
sera punie
soit à l'enfer
soit en Christ
ok
et en introduisant
la punition
Dieu va introduire
aussi une nouvelle alliance
et dans cette nouvelle alliance
donc on n'aura pas
le temps de rentrer
dans tous les détails
mais je voulais
appeler votre attention
surtout
à partir du verset 14
et ça c'est vraiment
très intéressant
très glorieux
et c'est un motif
qu'on verra
à chaque étape
car
dans toutes les alliances
que Dieu établit
au long de l'histoire
nous pouvons identifier
quelques éléments
d'alliances
les promesses
les parties concernées
mais
à chaque fois
qu'une alliance
est établie
dans l'histoire
surtout dans l'histoire
de l'Ancien Testament
les médiateurs
sont typologiques
et il pointera
toujours
envers les médiateurs
parfaits
qu'est Jésus Christ
et quand on arrivera
au Nouveau Testament
c'est glorieux de voir
que Paul
lorsqu'il va traiter
l'alliance abramique
en Galate
il va dire
car la promesse
a été faite
à Abraham
et à son descendant
mais tout de suite
il va se concentrer
surtout
à son descendant
c'est-à-dire
même si une alliance
était établie
avec Abraham
l'alliance était
en train d'être établie
à travers Abraham
à Jésus Christ
cette alliance
qui était déjà établie
avant la fondation
du monde
avec Christ
et donc ces médiateurs
donc remarquez bien
car
on a plutôt l'impression
en lisant les passages
qu'Adam
elle est première
appelée
pour contempler
toute cette affaire
il appelle
l'homme d'abord
pour qu'il puisse
rendre compte
et Dieu va faire
ses déclarations
y compris la promesse
de ce qu'on appelle
les proto-évangiles
mais là
on va voir
que tout de suite
Adam est plutôt perçu
comme un expectateur
plutôt qu'un médiateur
il reste
les représentants
de la race humaine
dans deux sens
en tant que les représentants
de toute la race pécheresse
qui passera
à dépendre
totalement
de la grâce de Dieu
pour être sauvé
il sera
les représentants
de cette famille
biologique humaine
dont viendra
les descendants
de la femme
mais cette promesse
est faite
à l'humanité
à partir
de la sémence
donc c'est
à nouveau
c'est comme si
on était en train
de voir
que l'alliance
ou la promesse
elle est faite
plutôt avec
les descendants
de la femme
car c'est lui
qui va devoir
accomplir ce qu'il faut
c'est lui
qui va devoir
écraser la tête
du serpent
c'est lui
qui souffrira
les coups du serpent
et donc
quand on voit
les passages
dans les détails
on va voir
que Dieu dit au serpent
puisque tu as fait cela
tu seras maudit
entre tous les bétails
et entre tous les aliments
des champs
tu marcheras
sur ton ventre
et tu mangeras
de la poussière
tous les jours
de ta vie
je mettrai
l'illimitié
entre toi
et la femme
entre ta postérité
et sa postérité
et Paul
va mettre
beaucoup d'emphase
sur le fait
que cette postérité
s'agit d'un seul
du Christ
de Messie
et donc
celle-ci
t'écrasera la tête
et tu lui blesseras
les talons
et donc
ici
c'est ce qu'on appelle
les proto-évangiles
et ici
nous voyons déjà
cette essence profonde
des grâces
car
qu'est-ce qui nous a amené
à la rébellion
c'était
une amitié
entre la femme
et les serpents
la femme
et Satan
et la solidarité
de l'homme
dans cette amitié
il a plutôt voulu
joindre la société
des rebelles
et des pécheurs
dans cette amitié
et l'homme
par nature
c'est impossible
qu'il casse
cette domination
cette amitié
dans la rébellion
avec Satan
c'est impossible
de nous-mêmes
et donc ici
la promesse principale
c'est la réconciliation
c'est l'amitié
avec Dieu rétabli
mais à nouveau
en prénonçant
une division
sans terrain neutre
par rapport
au fruit
de cette association
entre la femme
et les serpents
donc la descendance
de la femme
et la descendance
du serpent
vous comprenez
et ça va marquer
l'histoire de l'humanité
donc
certains
auront
cette rupture
car
ils seront comptés
entre la descendance
de la foi
d'Adam
envers
les descendants
mais la race humaine
sera pour toujours
divisée
entre ceux
qui sont appelés
les fils
du diable
fils de cette amitié
et les fils
de la foi
d'Adam
donc ça commence
tout de suite
avec Caïn et Abel
et plus tard
avec les descendants
de Noé
comme on voit
dans l'histoire
mais bon
ici nous voyons déjà
la promesse
c'est la réconciliation
avec Dieu
et ensuite
vers la fin
je vais
venir plutôt
vers
les versets
les constats
des dieux
et voilà
là
on doit être
très judicieux
à ne pas faire
trop de conjectures
les éléments
d'alliance
ils sont clairs
mais ils sont essentiels
et ça c'est très important
car vous allez remarquer
aussi
dans l'argumentation
de l'apôtre Paul
qu'il va
reconnecter
l'alliance des dieux
surtout
à Adam
Christ en étant
les nouvelles Adam
et c'est une alliance
qui se porte
envers toute l'humanité
là on n'a pas encore
les Israélites
on n'a pas encore
la circoncision
ces peuples
c'est cette descendance
universelle quelque part
qui aura tous ces représentants
par contre
ici
nous voyons
que cette
que cette descendance
voilà
on identifie
pardon
la promesse
on identifie
les parties
mais
les signes
ou les sauts
ne sont pas clairs
pour nous
dans les cadres
de cette première alliance
donc on a quelques pistes
par exemple
on peut penser
et il n'y a même pas
c'est intéressant
mais on a explicite
des sanctions
pour cette alliance
tout est tellement
concentré
sur les
sur les descendants
de la femme
qu'on n'a même pas
comme c'est une alliance
tellement explicitement
des grâces
qu'on n'a même pas
une mention
explicite
à la sanction
même la sanction
qui semble être
une sanction
c'est pour nous priver
de manger
et de vivre éternellement
dans une condition
de péché
c'est la grâce
de Dieu
de nous empêcher
de revenir au paradis
pour qu'on ne mange pas
du fruit de la vie
et qu'on rende
la condition
de péché
éternelle
donc ici
nous voyons
ces éléments
importants
les chérubans
les pifs
flamboyantes
pour garder
les chemins
de l'art de la vie
et donc là
c'est la première alliance
qu'on voit
des grâces
par nécessité
et bien sûr
selon la sagesse
des dieux
donc la prochaine alliance
qu'on voit dans la bible
c'est l'alliance
abrahamique
et là c'est aussi
une alliance
devant laquelle
on doit s'arrêter
et la présentation
du pacte
des dieux
ou l'alliance
avec abraham
et donc
ce qu'on doit
remarquer
c'est qu'ici
nous voyons
déjà
plusieurs éléments
qui faisaient
partie des alliances
de l'époque
du proche orient
voilà
environ
2000 ans
avant jésus christ
donc là
on avait
les sacrifices
rituels
donc ce qu'on verra
ce sont
des animaux
découpés
qui vont être
placés
dans un couloir
et normalement
les deux parties
devraient
traverser
mais dieux
vous vous rappelez
l'histoire
fait qu'abraham
soit endormi
et dieux seul
va passer
par cette représentation
des feux
comme en disant
voilà
si jamais
cette alliance
est brisée
toutes les sanctions
vont pas retomber
sur moi
et toi
elles retomberont
toutes sur moi
donc c'est
qu'est dieux
qui passe
par les couloirs
des punitions
ou des sanctions
dans cette alliance
c'est qu'il nous rappelle
que la grâce
est là
mais même
l'explicite manière
dont le passage
nous dit
que la foi d'abraham
a servi
d'amputation
pour sa justice
c'est qu'il permet
à Abraham
de réjouir
de toutes les bénédictions
promises
ok
donc les deux parties
d'un côté
on a
Dieu
et de l'autre côté
chez Abraham
nous avons
plutôt
les peuples
universels
de l'humanité
en toi
ou dans ton descendant
toutes les nations
seront bénies
donc ça reste
encore assez
assez
universel
donc c'est
l'humanité
par rapport
à ces peuples
et ensuite
quand on arrive
donc bien sûr
j'ai sauté
l'alliance noétique
car
l'alliance abrahamique
elle est
la première révélation
la plus explicite
d'une alliance
la plus complète
Moïse
mais la première révélation
explicite
d'une alliance formelle
c'est avec Abraham
mais bien sûr
avec Noël
juste pour cette progression
lui
il est représentant
de toute la création
mais bien sûr
que les symboles
principales
ou les sceaux
ou les signes
et l'arc-en-ciel
qui va utiliser
du même élément
de la punition
pour communiquer
de la grâce
avec beauté
de l'eau
mais on voit
comment dans cette histoire
Noël
il était un médiateur
qui devrait quand même
être protégé
par cette arche
et qui représente
pour nous
les Christs
donc c'est en Jésus
que toute la création
est protégée
nous voyons
en Noël
une alliance
avec toute la création
et là
la chose va
encore plus
se resserrer
ceux
de la descendance
de la foi
d'Abraham
donc
composée
par toutes les nations
mais
les Christs
ils viendraient
à travers
Abraham biologique
donc à partir de là
on a cette préservation
d'un peuple
qui n'a aucune valeur
de soi-même
mais
ce qui est
l'argument
ou l'un des arguments
principaux
de l'apôtre
Paul
c'est de démontrer
comment
même si
l'alliance
mosaïque
elle était plus
complexe
dans sa formalité
elle n'était pas
supérieure
ni contradictoire
à l'alliance
avec Abraham
qui était
une alliance
établie
dans sa formalité
avant même
de communiquer
les signes
car les signes
de cette alliance
étaient la circoncision
les besoins
d'une expiation
et l'espérance
que les descendants
viennent
de cette sémence
d'Abraham
donc les descendants
d'un miracle
mais c'est important
quand on va discuter
l'application
par exemple
du signe
de l'alliance
par exemple
pour certains
il faut
baptiser les enfants
car Abraham
a circonci les enfants
mais l'argument
de l'apôtre Paul
c'est que
la formalité
de cette alliance
était déjà parfaite
avant même
que Dieu ajoute
ces symboles-là
qui avaient
un objectif
aussi temporel
et biologique
pour marquer
ces peuples
et ça devient
encore plus clair
une fois que
l'alliance
avec Moïse est établie
car c'est une alliance
plutôt nationale
qui aura lieu
et donc
l'alliance
abrahamique
est là
d'un côté
les seigneurs
pardon
Abraham
et sa postérité
et cette postérité
particulière
qui est
Christ lui-même
je dois avancer là
je n'aurai pas le temps
de lire tous les passages
mais
je vous encourage
et donc ici
c'est important pour nous
pour établir quelques bases
c'est pour être
au clair
en fait
l'argument
je pense que c'est important
à retenir
surtout pour nous
baptistes
créés de baptistes
qui concernent
ces points-là
c'est que
depuis l'alliance
avec Adam
nous sommes devant
déjà une alliance
moins explicite
mais essentielle
et parfaite
et aucune alliance
ne peut la contredire
par contre
l'alliance avec Abraham
étant la première alliance
formelle
même si ces éléments
qui composent
cette première alliance
avant la circoncision
et avant même
qu'il n'y ait des descendants
et 400 ans
avant la loi
c'est
une
catégorie
des bases
très importantes
pour nous
car l'argument
pédobaptiste
l'un des arguments
principaux
qu'ils utilisent
c'est de prendre
les alliances
les plus complètes
dans la Bible
notamment celle
des Moïse
et l'alliance
complète
tardive
d'Abraham
pour dire
que l'application
du symbole
on doit suivre
un peu
les mêmes éléments
la même
systématisation
des alliances
par contre
l'argument dépôle
dans ces passages
c'est de dire
que l'alliance
était déjà parfaite
on aura beaucoup plus
d'autres arguments
traités bien sûr
mais je voulais juste
poser cette catégorie
pour nous
c'est clair pour vous
oui ou non
pas trop
ok
donc
quand on va
défendre
les baptêmes d'enfants
l'un des arguments
qu'on utilise
c'est que
quand on contemple
les alliances
les plus
complètes
dans la Bible
notamment
on va penser
à Moïse
et l'alliance
avec Abraham
plus tard
avec la circoncision
dessinée aussi
pour les enfants
c'est que
nous devons
chercher
à trouver
dans les nouveaux
testaments
une application
similaire
aux alliances
les plus complètes
de l'ancien testament
par contre
l'argument
de Paul
en Galate
c'est que
cette alliance
était déjà
parfaite
même avant
la circoncision
la descendance
même avant
Israël national
et donc là
il veut convaincre
que la vraie
descendance
d'Israël
est la descendance
de la foi
que la dispensation
du nouveau testament
est l'église
composée
des chrétiens
et nous
les baptistes
ne nous voyons pas
d'essence
à chercher
à appliquer
tous les éléments
tous les principes
et tous les éléments
des alliances
plus complètes
de l'ancien testament
pour déterminer
les critères
pour la nouvelle alliance
c'est un peu plus clair
là
ok
et donc
ce qu'on voit là
en Galate
en lisant
or la loi
n'est pas fondée
sur la foi
mais elle dit
celui qui mettra
ces choses en pratique
vivra par elle
Christ nous a racheté
de la malédiction
de la loi
étant devenu
malédiction pour nous
car il a été écrit
maudit
à quiconque
est pendu au bois
afin que la bénédiction
d'Abraham
eut pour les païens
son accomplissement
en Jésus Christ
donc on s'appelle
que la bénédiction
d'Abraham
comprenait aussi
les païens
et que nous ressuscions
par la foi
l'esprit
qui avait été promis
donc là
l'esprit
qui reçoit
tous ceux
qui participent
à la foi
d'Abraham
ok
la nature
de la descendance
d'Abraham
est prédominant
et prééminante
celle de la foi
ceux qui reçoivent
l'esprit
frère
je parle à la manière
des hommes
donc ça c'est
la thèse
de l'apôtre Paul
c'est
le saint-esprit
est la marque
de la nouvelle alliance
ok
et c'est ça
qui doit déterminer
l'importance
ou non
d'une marque
envers tous les peuples
qui sera là
et si ça concerne
ceux ou pas
qui ont ou non
l'esprit
dans la nouvelle alliance
et donc frère
je parle
à la manière
des hommes
une disposition
en bonne forme
bien qu'il est faite
par un homme
n'est annulée
par personne
et personne n'y ajoute
donc si même un homme
rentre dans un traité
qui est déjà suffisamment
parfait
ou suffisamment
correct
aucune chose
qui viendra après
ne peut le contredire
ok
c'est un
c'est un traité
formel
si c'est
si c'est la vérité
pour les hommes
l'argument de Paul
c'est
c'est impossible
d'imaginer
que lorsque Dieu
va donner la loi
à Moïse
il soit en train
de nous donner
à nouveau
en salut
par les oeuvres
vous comprenez
l'argument de Paul
c'est
une fois
que Dieu
donne la loi
à Moïse
elle peut signifier
plusieurs choses
mais la seule chose
qu'elle ne peut pas signifier
c'est une contradiction
avec cette alliance
qui avait été d'abord
établie avec Abraham
ok
et donc
afin qu'il y ait la bénédiction
avec Abraham
pardon
je parle à la manière
des hommes
donc
or les promesses
ont été faites
à Abraham
et à sa postérité
ok
il n'est pas dit
et aux postérités
comme s'il s'agissait
de plusieurs
mais en étant
qu'il s'agit d'une seule
et à ta postérité
c'est à dire
à Christ
donc c'est ce que Paul
est en train de dire
c'est que
c'est important
c'est que Dieu
a fait une promesse
de bénir toute l'humanité
par un descendant
qui viendrait biologiquement
de cette nation
de ce peuple
d'Abraham
et sa descendance
par contre
c'est
c'est lui
le descendant
qui va déterminer
les vrais saluts
et qui va déterminer
les vrais peuples
des dieux
c'est pas
la descendance biologique
d'Abraham
c'est la descendance
de la foi
d'Abraham
car
c'est à Christ
que la promesse
a été faite
et ayant fait
la promesse
ou l'alliance
si vous voulez
avec Christ
c'est clair
que
dans la période
ou la dispensation
de l'accomplissement
de cette alliance
une fois
accomplie
la venue du Christ
ça serait une contradiction
de chercher
à établir
d'autres bases
qu'exclosivement
celle de la foi
d'Abraham
pour déterminer
ceux qui sont
les peuples
de cette alliance
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc là
c'est la défense
de l'apôtre Paul
pour que
les Galates
ne se laissent pas
circoncirent
ok
c'est en disant
si les Saint-Esprits
sont là
la marque
de la nouvelle
est déjà là
ceux qui participent
à cette alliance
sont là
car vous avez
déjà la foi
et donc voici
ce que j'entends
une disposition
qui Dieu a formé
intérieurement
ne peut pas être annulée
et ainsi la promesse
rendue vaine
par la loi
survélue
430 ans
après
ou plus tard
pardon
car si l'héritage
venait de la loi
il ne viendrait plus
de la promesse
or
c'est par la promesse
que Dieu a fait à Abraham
c'est donc
des grâces
de sa grâce
pourquoi donc la loi
elle a été donnée
ensuite à cause
des transgressions
jusqu'à ce qu'il vient
la postérité
à qui la promesse
avait été faite
elle a été promulguée
par des anges
au moyen d'un médiateur
je ne peux pas rentrer
dans tous les détails
mais c'est une double
médiation
donc ce n'était pas
une alliance
si importante
comme celle faite
directement avec Abraham
ok
les anges d'une part
Moïse d'autre part
pour représenter le peuple
une distance plus grande
et
l'emphase principale
de cette alliance
c'était
une emphase déjà
dans les cadres
de la grâce
c'est une loi
qui a été donnée
après la libération
de l'Egypte
ok
après les saluts
complètement dépendant
de la grâce de Dieu
sur la base
du sang de l'agneau
qui représentait bien sûr
les Christs
et donc cette alliance
faite avec Abraham
avec Moïse
elle ne peut pas
surmonter
en importance
ni contredire
dans aucun cas
et donc la loi
mosaïque
elle est
subserviente
à la loi
qui a été donnée
à Abraham
c'est à dire
elle va jouer
un rôle gracieux aussi
même si un rôle
plus dur
de nous convaincre
qu'aucun autre
moment
n'arrive
à accomplir
la loi
et de nous convaincre
des punitions
qu'on mériterait
devant les exigences
saintes
des dieux
et Paul va dire
c'est comme
il nous mettait
ces choses
qu'on met
dans les yeux
des oeillères
pour garder
nos yeux fixés
dans la promesse
dans les descendants
qui viendraient
accomplir parfaitement
toutes les choses
la grâce est évidente
chez Moïse
par les rôles
de suprême sacrificateur
des sacrifices expiratoires
et donc par là
nous ne sommes pas
devant
des nouvelles conditions
à travers lesquelles
on pourrait
trouver les saluts
ça c'est la correction
des pôles
envers une attitude
des légalistes
qui ne sont pas
les bons juifs
ne sont pas ceux
qui ont compris
vraiment
l'évangile
à partir
de ce que Dieu
voulait communiquer
par la loi
ce n'était jamais
un moyen
des rédemptions
c'était un moyen
des sanctifications
des bases
pour les peuples
des dieux
et des conditions
qui marquent
toutes les alliances
car même nous
qui sommes en Jésus Christ
nous ne sommes pas
absents
des lois
ceux qui ont
mes commandements
avec les gâtes
ce sont ceux qui m'aiment
c'est une question
des constats
des réjouissances
c'est une question
des disciplines
et encadrément
dans un cadre
des grâces
si vous voulez
ok
et donc là
c'est
pour avancer un peu
ces rapports
entre
l'alliance d'Abraham
et l'alliance
avec Moïse
je laisserai
les éléments
qui composent
une alliance
plus complète
pour plus tard
pour la prochaine occasion
et aussi
l'abordage
de la nouvelle alliance
en Christ
mais j'aimerais
quand même
vous apporter
une perspective
plus globale
donc avec David
il y a cette
dernière
alliance
avant la venue
du Christ
qui va mettre
plus en phase
sur les rôles
royales du Christ
et donc
une médiation
plus
typologique
de la réalité
du Christ
quand il viendra
et donc
les symboles
c'était
les trônes
les temples
etc
les sanctions
étaient la discipline
on a vu
comment David
a souffert énormément
par les péchés
qu'il a commis
en laissant
d'être
un bon modèle
des royalties
pour Israël
et combien Israël
a aussi souffert
à cause de ça
mais
la promesse
a été quand même
maintenue
et Christ
est venu
à travers
la descendance
de David
donc
quelle est la conclusion
qu'on doit
arriver
je vais arrêter
là aujourd'hui
donc
la définition
d'une alliance
biblique
c'est
une alliance
est un pacte
solennel
par lequel Dieu
par initiative
souveraine
et condescendance
divine
se lie
à l'homme
pour son salut
et sa bénédiction
contrairement
aux alliances humaines
entre parties égales
Dieu prend la priorité
et l'initiative
s'engageant
à tenir ses promesses
indépendamment
de la capacité humaine
cette alliance
peut comporter
des conditions
pour l'homme
des signes
ou des cérémonies
mais elle reflète
toujours la grâce
et la miséricorde
des dieux
et trouve son accomplissement
ultime
dans l'oeuvre
rédemptrice
du Seigneur Jésus Christ
ça on verra
dans la prochaine fois
et donc
pour résumer
les vérités
les plus importantes
à retenir
aujourd'hui
c'est
les grands descents
de la rédemption
des dieux
est structuré
par une unique alliance
ok
après la chute
une seule alliance
cette alliance
des grâces
s'est historiquement
manifestée
sous deux grandes
administrations
ou dispensations
si vous voulez
c'est pas
les dispensationalismes
scatologiques
et scatologiques
voilà
mais
il s'agit
quand même
des deux
grandes administrations
des dieux
dans l'histoire
pour communiquer
cette alliance
des grâces
donc la première
on appelle
l'ancienne alliance
et
la deuxième
on appelle
la nouvelle alliance
donc
l'ancienne alliance
comprend
diverses alliances
particulières
qui sont
des administrations
progressives
typologiques
et temporelles
de cette
unique alliance
des grâces
révélées
dès après la chute
et fondées
dans l'alliance
éternelle
entre trinitaires
donc c'est intéressant
important
de nous rappeler
que cette alliance
est avant
la fondation du monde
et qu'elle est
communiquée
déjà
à partir
de la chute
cette alliance
des grâces
a été accomplie
dans l'histoire
par l'obéissance
parfaite
ou la satisfaction
de tous les termes
qui soutenaient
même par anticipation
la réalité
de cette alliance
pour ceux
de l'Ancien Testament
donc Christ
dans l'histoire
va accomplir
tous les termes
par son obéissance
parfaite
et son œuvre
rédemptrice
et lui
il est donc
les médiateurs
suprêmes
et efficaces
et elle
est appliquée
avec puissance
par les saints
esprits
aux élus
et donc
voilà
les survols
et si vous voulez
un graphique
pour conclure
c'est
cette idée
il y a eu
une alliance
éternelle
avant la fondation
du monde
qui Dieu a établi
au long
de l'histoire
dans l'Ancien Testament
dans l'Ancien Alliance
Dieu a révélé
progressivement
par plusieurs
alliances
avec ces hommes-là
en communiquant
à chaque fois
des aspects
plus riches
qui concernent
cette alliance
et au moment
où Christ vient
et qu'il accomplit
tous les termes
parfaits
donc il est
les vrais médiateurs
de l'alliance
donc c'est déjà
même dans l'Ancien Alliance
en Christ
en fait
que toutes ces alliances
sont maintenues
c'est par la foi
dans les Messies
qui viendra
qu'ils pouvaient
réjouir de leur pardon
et du niveau
d'intimité
avec Dieu
qu'ils avaient
mais bien sûr
que la réjouissance
de l'intimité divine
une fois
que tout est accompli
est infiniment supérieure
en termes
d'intensité
de réjouissance
des bénédictions
de la nouvelle alliance
et donc ça
c'est l'histoire
de l'Église
après Christ
on est déjà
élevé
notre vie
est cachée
dans les lieux célestes
et donc la réjouissance
que nous avons
elle est infiniment supérieure
à tous ceux
que ces hommes
ont pu réjouir
même si c'était
la même grâce
c'était la même foi
et les mêmes objets
de la foi
qui nous avons
aujourd'hui
mais de manière
moins claire
et moins intense
et donc voilà
nous sommes en train
de réjouir
de la nouvelle alliance
en Jésus Christ
et donc on est